hello welcome to the last talk at the
conference
um so a lot of the time I do these last
talks at the conference thing and
they're like the worst programming
language ever or programming's greatest
mistakes and and they're hilarious and
everyone laughs this isn't that this is
actually sort of technical
um and and sort of uh opinion based I
hesitate to use the phrase opinion based
because that suggests that I'm not
necessarily right and I definitely am
um
and and the title you're doing it wrong
it's possible that you're not doing it
wrong you might be doing exactly what
I'm going to talk about here in which
case you're doing it right
um and you can go back to your company
and say well we are doing it right Mark
Rendell agrees with me and they will
have no option but to say who the hell
is Mark Rendell
um so yes
uh so anyway I'm hoping I'm gonna maybe
change a few people's minds um this is
an entrenched thing that I'm going to be
talking about uh and uh you've got to
start somewhere so I'm starting here and
then they'll put it on YouTube hello
YouTube Cheapskates
um
and there we go there's some negative
comments already uh and yeah so let's
let's crack on with it anyway so open
API
I've lost my monitor
um so I'm gonna have to turn around and
look at the slides which is very
unprofessional until the monitor comes
back
um so yes right let's go back to that
one because it's there so what is it
um obligatory Red Dwarf quote uh
because I'm old
if you haven't seen Red Dwarf it's
probably on one of the streaming
services like um Brit box or something
like that so check it out
um but no so open API is a structured uh
uh data format for describing apis
um and it was started uh as Swagger and
Swagger was kind of like an independent
thing it was just pushed by this one
company and then Swagger became open API
2.0 and uh it had some some deficiencies
and everything so they used that as the
bouncing off point and then they came up
with version 3.0 which is the current
version of open API and there is a
slightly newer version uh called 3.1
which has got a few changes and and
usability enhancements over 3.0 and then
there's a 4.0 kind of
out there prospective ideas for the next
version project which I'll talk about a
little bit at the end
but uh use this one
oh yeah no I remember this from the last
time I gave this talk I forgot to turn
off the animations on my copied and
pasted slide if you've seen
programming's greatest mistakes you'll
know how many of those are copy and
paste problems so yes the one you should
be using at the moment is 3.0 3.1 lovely
new and improved not very well supported
by editors and all the tooling and all
that sort of stuff doesn't really
support it properly yet so
um I suspect all of that will catch up
just as 4.0 gets released and everyone
wants to use that
so the implementation it kind of
thickers up on here and then it
disappears again
um I think we killed it last night uh so
yes the implementation of open API this
is the thing I really want to talk about
okay because
NDC most people come to NDC conferences
are DOT net developers
some sometimes you get Java developers
who thought it was a go-to and they've
just got terribly terribly lost and and
they have to watch all these talks about
the superior technology
um
but so I'm assuming most people here are
building apis in.net
hopefully.net6 uh maybe dot Net 7 if you
work for one of those companies that
goes yeah no it's fine we'll use the
current release we don't need LTS and
when you do open API what people think
of as open API in.net is swashbuckle or
end swag and swashbuckle actually if you
dot net new web API now it dumps
swashbuckle in there for you and the way
that you add open API to your project is
this you have your controller action
method that returns an action result and
it has a parameter from body ad book
which is your model that you're using to
serialize as Json and pass up there and
without any of these attributes you can
sort of produce a barely usable Swagger
UI page that will sort of go well
there's a thing and it's called this and
the path is this and it takes these
parameters other than that I have no
idea and so you want it to be sort of
more descriptive and so you add all
these parameters you go produces
response type so all the different
responses the thing can produce you
document them in in attributes I have uh
at the place where I'm currently working
where they're very big into there should
be proper open API documentation for all
the apis and there are a lot of apis and
um
three or four lines of code so get
something by the ID and it's like we got
an injected Cosmos repository so we get
it and then we return it it's like three
lines of code and then 15 lines of
attributes to try and get the open API
documentation to to work properly
that's how we do it in.net that's how we
have been
raised by Microsoft to expect things to
work this kind of Microsoft have a
history of this
asp.net the original asp.net web forms
the whole point of that was that it
looked a lot like Windows forms so
people who had been using Visual Basic
to build Windows applications could
switch over to using either vb.net or
c-sharp to produce web applications but
they could pretend that they were still
building desktop applications so they
said on click on a button and it
completely hid the fact that that was
doing a round trip to the server and
doing magic and then chucking it back
down there with a megabyte of view state
to make it work and then there was net
remote and then that got replaced by WCF
which supported soap as the the hot new
thing in 2006 time is just going so fast
now
and and with WCF you basically built
your into built your interface and you
put service contracts and data contracts
and operation contract on stuff and it
generated the soap XML file and you're
kind of like fair enough actually
because the wisdal files that it sent
nobody wanted to write those by hand
but everybody else
in the entire tech industry when they
want to do open API they open a text
editor and they edit the open api.yaml
file and they put the information in
there and then they build the the API to
match that specification and actually
you can get code generators that will
generate you a basic node.js Express JS
application based on your open API
specification it's only in.net that we
do this thing the wrong way around
and I'm going to argue that everybody
else is doing it right and we are doing
it wrong
and that handcrafted artisanal yaml
files are what we should be using just
like everybody else
and the thing that triggered this for me
so the place where I'm working at the
moment very very API heavy very micro
Services
uh lots of things running in Azure
functions way too many my Nano Services
actually we need to sort of collapse
some of those Nano Services into just
microservices and
every one of these apis they have a
GitHub repo and
they've got the swashbuckle in there
they've got the swashbuckle plug-in to
make it work with Azure functions and it
works it generates the the Swagger UI
page and you can try things out and all
that sort of stuff
and then in the GitHub repo they've got
an api.md markdown file
which is hand maintained Which documents
the API so that you can go to GitHub and
I was looking at this and it's kind of
hash hash and then the path and then
get and then a quick description line
and then a code sample with a kind of
this is the the schema for the object
and a dotted lists and nested lists and
all this sort of stuff and I'm kind of
like
you're recreating open API yaml in
markdown
so you're still having to hand maintain
this thing because you want the
information in your GitHub repository
but you're not just using the thing
that's already out there and has editor
support and standards and linters and
intellisense and all these kinds of
things you're just recreating that ad
hoc in markdown why are we doing that
and so hence this talk
because
you know
yaml
you can write your open API
specification in Json if you don't mind
wearing out your shift two keys on your
keyboard with all the the double quotes
unless you're American in which case
it's kind of somewhere over by the
return key oh I don't know anyway
um but yes uh people kind of say oh I
hate the animal the animal is the worst
serialization format yaml is the worst
structured data format and I would argue
that yes yaml is the worst structured
data format except for all the others
it's basically Json without the double
quotes and curly races all over the
place yes It suffers from the same thing
that python can suffer from which is
when some idiot checks it out into a
editor with tabs instead of spaces they
will break everything but
if you want to do anything these days
You're editing yaml files uh if you're
going to have GitHub actions to do
builds if you're going to run things in
kubernetes if you're going to do any of
this sort of devops stuff or CI CD stuff
you've got yaml files in there somewhere
so just accept it someone at some point
will come up with something better or a
better way of editing yaml files but for
the time being let's just deal with it
back in the day so I've been doing this
for a very long time I've been doing uh
professional software development since
I was 17 years old which was uh 1990.
and when I first started and I went out
Contracting and I was writing software
in Infamous 4gl on Unix systems and it
was full waterfall there was a thing
called ssadm which was a kind of design
and implementation methodology and
prints too as well and you weren't
allowed to write a line of code until
somebody had given you a specification
that detailed every single line of code
that you were supposed to write and you
were just kind of so you'd lit you're
translating some business analysts
description of the system line by line
into C or inFAMOUS 4gl or whatever the
language was and at the time we used to
say why can't we just have specs that
compile
um what and if or even specs that can be
validated specs that you could lint and
say does this spec make sense does it
have all the information that is needed
and now we have
openapi.yaml and for API specs that's
exactly what that is it is a standard
you can lint it you can intelli sense it
you can do all this sort of stuff and
we're getting to the point where you can
just compile it
um and and it will become a working
application
why why do you want us to edit yaml
files by hand why do you hate us
uh
this is the key thing so if you are the
only person working on an API then this
argument holds less weight because you
know it's just you and you're noodling
away at the thing and it's fine just
just use Swagger and swashbuckle or end
swag or whatever but as soon as you have
two people or three people or four
people working on the same project and
you're building sort of you know this
guy is doing that controller and that
girl's doing the other controller and
whatever else is going on you need to
have a source of Truth you need to go
this is the schema for the user object
this is the schema for the product
object
um and this is the format that URLs will
take and this is the standard that we're
going to use for error reporting in Json
objects and that sort of thing and at
that point you want a design document
and you want some standards in your
project and yeah you could do markdown
files you could maintain a Word document
you could put it wherever you want to do
it but open API is right there saying
hello I am the accepted standardized
shared widely understood supported by
tools way of doing this please use me
you create an open api.yaml file you put
it into your source code repository
somebody wants to change the
specification they open a pull request
yeah you can't open a pull request on a
page in confluence
if you have to use Confluence and if you
have to use Confluence I am going to at
some point get NDC to let me set up a
booth
where people who have to use atlassian
software in their jobs can come and get
a hug
can't do completely no jokes
um you know it's atlassian
um but yes Confluence specs in
Confluence Pages someone comes along and
changes it there's no review process
there's no what about this and so forth
open api.yaml file git merge can cope
with it really nicely because it's
structured get merge kind of understand
structured things and it can go through
a review it can go through uh people
nitpicking on things and everything else
so it's that it becomes that single
source of Truth for your team
it separates the design and the
implementation and there's that that
famous saying that with six weeks of
coding you can save yourself literally
six hours of design time
um
but sitting around a whiteboard and I'm
actually uh I think it's first time is
going to be at NDC Oslo I have a new
two-day workshop on designing and
implementing apis and it starts off with
the Whiteboard and going okay so this is
the API it's it's interesting because
it's going to be a different Workshop
every time because I'm not going to tell
them what's right it's just uh idea
storming at the start and saying oh
should we have this object and that
object but you start around a whiteboard
and you design it and you show the links
and the ways of getting from this place
to that place and all this sort of stuff
but when it comes time to write that
down into a form that then becomes the
uh the driver for the project you codify
it as open API and then you've got your
open api.yaml file in your repository
and you work on the code until what
happens matches what the specs is if
this is separate design and
implementation
um it's a better description of your API
so I'm going to show you some of the
stuff that you can stick into these yaml
files if you hand craft them artisanally
and getting them into
swashbuckle or end swag it's possible
but some of the ways you have to do it
have really really disgusting there's
like callbacks and assembly attributes
and all sorts of mad stuff in there
whereas you can just type it in you can
put mark down in some of the sections
and the renderers will nicely format
that for you with bold sections and code
syntax highlighted sections and
everything so you actually have a better
a human Focus description of your API
rather than what the machine generates
and finally and I'll show you a couple
of examples of this you have automated
documentation so as far as most.net
developers are concerned the
documentation is Swagger UI Swagger UI
is not documentation it's a it's a hack
it and try it interface but it's not
documentation you can produce actual
static documentation which you can
include in your GitHub repository so
your application doesn't even need to be
running for somebody to learn how to use
it imagine that
um
this is not open API this is protobuf uh
Proto buff
and grpc which is another thing that I'm
quite hot on uh
you define your messages and you define
your services in the protobuf language
and then you compile that with proto-c
and it generates the classes and the
stubs for the services and then you
override things and you implement it and
everything else and again
huh
in.net
uh there are multiple
um ways of doing this so Mark gravel who
is an extremely talented developer who I
have an enormous amount of respect for
has a code first way of doing both
protobuf and grpc you create C sharp
code and you annotate it with attributes
and it generates the Proto file at
runtime
um
but
the other way of doing it is to write
the Proto file and then use the official
grpc.net libraries to generate those
base classes and the difference is that
by doing that you can get a file that
you're sharing with your users which is
how they create their client to interact
with your service but also has all this
it has comments
this is the other reason why yaml is a
superior format to Json because yaml
supports comments and Jason doesn't so
when you go to use the money type from
Google apis you don't have to go well
what's units and Nanos what does that
mean because there's comments in the
Proto file to explain to you how that
works
so let's start looking at open API
because this is the other thing that
that I've noticed is it's generated for
us so you look at you go to slash
Swagger
and you get the UI thing comes up quite
a lot of dotnet developers who've
probably been using this stuff for for
years now actually have no idea what
open API itself looks like they don't
know they've never looked at it they
just look at Swagger and they go that's
it that's what open API is so let's
let's actually dig into what you've got
in here so at the top I say this is an
open API file and this is version of
3.0.0 at which point Visual Studio code
kicks the open API extensions that I
have installed and they come to life and
start putting red squiggles under
everything because I've done it wrong
um but uh so I use that as my my top
level thing and then I have this info
section getting this info section in
using n swag or swashbuckle is
challenging it's it's no obvious way of
doing it
um and so I have a title for my uh my
API and I tell you which version it is
um and then I put contact information in
there because I'm nice and if you have
problems with my API I want you to be
able to contact me we're in a fantasy
world here okay so let's just go with it
and imagine that I'm that kind of person
so it's got my name and my email and a
URL where you can find out more and then
we have tags we can tag things and
things can have more than one tag and if
I have this tag section at the top here
I can add additional information to the
tags like descriptions and so forth and
then all I have to do is reference that
tag elsewhere in the document and all
that information will come with it
and then we have paths and uh we declare
so we have a paths section in our uh in
our yaml file and then beneath that we
have a series of objects Each of which
is the property name for it is a path so
here it's slash read slash or slash red
slash books
um English yay that's that's quite
obviously red and not read okay so just
we know and then below that you have
operations and you have get and then you
have an operation ID that gives it a
nice name which will display somewhere
very nice and then you have a summary of
what this is summary this is one of
those so anything that says description
or summary you can use yaml's sort of
multi-line text feature and you can dump
mark down in there and that will render
nicely into various user interfaces I
say this is part of the book section
this is uh got the Tag books on here and
then I have a response section and I say
okay this could respond with a 200 and
the description of that would be okay
and uh
I can provide more information in there
as well
so I can say that 200 okay it'll have
some content and when the content is
application Json then it will adhere to
this Json schema and I can reference
that and I can declare that at the end
of my yaml file and then reuse that
declaration all over the place and I can
put examples in there as well so you'll
see the the schema bit this is what it
looks like you'll see in Swagger UI if
you're using swashbuckle around swag but
the examples
um if you have something that can
generate them they'll be complete
nonsense if you hand code them you can
actually go you know this is a proper
example of what this might look like
schema
this is an interesting point so there's
a very good way of describing the
structure and types of Json documents
called Json schema and so
um of course open API supports Json
schema
almost
it doesn't uh it mostly supports it but
there's a bunch of things that you can
do in Json schema that open API
completely ignores and there's a couple
of things you can do in open API schema
that a Json schema validator will Chuck
a fit at so yes but you can essentially
describe your object to go as
application Json it's an object it's got
an ID property a title property a
finished app property which is a string
but it's got the format date time
because JavaScript and Json don't know
what a date is
and so you can put this information in
there as well
you can describe the parameters so we
can say so we have red slash book slash
ID so you can get a specific book that
you've read from my done that API all
these examples come from a thing that
I'm kind of building as an example
project for this called dundat because a
everybody does to-do lists and B to-do
lists are really stressful it's just
more psychic weight that I don't need
bearing down on me so I'm building a
done list
once I've done something I'll go I've
done it that's it it's fine I read it I
did a run I played a song Whatever it
might be
so yes anyway we've got a little
squiggly ID thing up in there and then
down here we can say oh there's a
parameter it's called ID it's in the
path you could put in query or in header
in there as well and then we've got a
schema and it's type is string so we
know that it's it's a string format so
you could put integer in there or float
or whatever and you can say it's
required so people know that you have to
put that in there because otherwise
you'll just get the the other end point
and we can describe requests as well in
much the same way so if we say I want to
say I I covered a distance
um then we
I really need to check my examples so we
go yes uh this is for measuring runs or
bike rides or walks or whatever you
might be doing and so when you want to
say oh I I covered a distance then you
need to specify a request body that
includes the author and the title of the
distance that you covered
um that should actually be how far was
it what units is that in and what were
you doing running cycling or walking
but never mind
I edited half of it and not the other
half never mind anyway
um but yes so you can you can specify
what your request should look like as
well
so doing that all the way you know if
you have to
um
copy and paste that schema and into
everything that's returning a book or
everything that's adding or updating a
distance or anything like that then
you're going to end up with the kind of
copy and paste mistakes that end up with
distances having authors and titles and
you don't want that so what you want is
a sort of shared area where you can
declare reusable components and so
there's a components section in an open
API spec and in there you can put
schemas responses request bodies
parameters headers security schemes
examples links and callbacks and so all
of these things if when you've got a
location header which is going to have a
URL in it you can just create a
component under headers that says
location or created or whatever you want
to call it and then you can just
reference that from wherever when you've
got a sort of standard
um
object to represent some data you put
that into schemas and then when you've
got a 200 response that returns that
object from various different places you
can create a standard response and then
reference that rather than writing out
response content their schema and
everything else
so you can reuse things like this
and it's incredibly easy you just have
components schemas book and then you
declare what that schema is and the same
thing with responses and examples and
everything else and then you can refer
to those
as hash slash components and just drag
them into other places in the spec and
open API passes will take care of
rehydrating that and doing all that
funky cool stuff
you can also have references to external
files
and so you can have a directory of
schema in your open API folder and in
there you can have book.yaml and you can
have an examples directory and you have
examples.yaml and you can reference
these things
the issue with doing this is that you
need to bundle it into a single yaml or
Json file for publishing because things
like Swagger UI and various other things
will not follow those links as a rule
um but there is a bundler and I'm
writing another one because why would I
let the fact that there already is one
stop me from writing my own
um
it's not written in.net is the simple
answer for that
um I'm going to release a whole bunch of
stuff where you type dot netspace open
API space and then magic things
um so yes and we have security I'm just
going to stop because it's I've just
remembered that I have code
that I can share with you so let's let's
take a look at some of this in actual
practice
so yeah here is my yaml file I'm going
to make that a little bit bigger is that
all right for people at the back
yay
um yes says someone two rows back
so yeah this is a full open API file
um I'm just going to make that right
there so I got my info there I've got
tags and each of my tags have
descriptions attached to them I've got a
security section where I'm saying auth
zero and that's an empty array this is a
really weird thing that I learned about
yaml while I was figuring out how to do
this stuff if you just want a property
name uh then uh
in an array of objects you have to put
in a property name and then an empty
array which is going just just use this
thing
um but yeah and then I have my paths and
I've got read books and that has a get
um and you can do get books and it
returns a list of completed books which
refers to schemas list of books and it
has an examples thing there and we have
a post operation to add a book and you
can see here that that uses the new book
um
schema but the example is just the title
would be Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy and the author would be Douglas
Adams and then we have a 201 response
which returns a 201 created response
and a 400 response which returns a bad
request and those are external so if I
go over here to responses and I can go
to 201 created
and ah so the description of this is
record created and it's not going to
have any content because you shouldn't
post operations really shouldn't return
the object you've just created they
should return a URL so you know how to
get it
um and so that's going to return a
location header which is declared yet
somewhere else and here we have a
location.yaml which is the absolute URI
of the created record and the type would
be string I'm pretty sure I could put
format
no I can't never mind
so yeah
um so going back to here we've got
various other things we've got uh
examples We've Got A Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy example and a mort example
uh we've got distances
um
where we can go down to the bottom and
see that we also have users we've got an
operation initialize user there here
we've got our examples and our schemas
are all declared and we've got a list of
books so when we have a list of
something we can just say the type of
this is array and the items and then we
refer over to the book that we've
already previously created
distance down here yeah there we go
that's more like it ID kilometers and
type new distance kilometers and type so
the new objects are generally
um
uh the same as the uh sort of actual
objects just minus one property it is
possible to do inheritance sort of with
Json schema so you can declare the new
object and then inherit the object with
the ID property from it and just add the
ID property but it's really ugly and I
hate it and so I don't like doing it but
for the distance type we say okay this
is a string but it's also an enum so it
can only be one of these three values so
when someone comes along and generates a
client it will actually generate an uh
an enumeration for that property so when
people pass it in they get to choose it
from a list of constants or an enum in
typescript or whatever it might be and
then down at the bottom here we have
security schemes
and we can say uh yeah so this has auth
zero which is oauth 2 with an implicit
flow using this authorization URL and
this scope or you can use client
credentials and there's a token URL at
that end point there so client
credentials for your desktop
applications implicit flow for saying uh
Scott Helm be damned I'm breaking oauth
and I know I am
okay
so yes that was the security bit you can
specify your security in there the other
thing is problems so it's no longer
enough just to return a 400 error and
that was a bad request as just
incredibly mean to say go ah you sent me
a request but it was bad and so I'm
refusing to serve it it really helps if
you send that person a little bit of
information about what exactly was wrong
with their request did they uh try and
pass a big number into a uuid field or
it was a value completely missing and so
there's a standard now which is actually
has its own mine type application slash
problem plus Json which you can return
back and it's got us what the error was
and where the error occurred and it will
handle multiple errors and it will tell
you everything that was wrong with your
thing an asp netcore will actually
generate that for you from the model
binding so if the model binding fails
because of the required attributes or
the regex attributes or anything else it
will just give you that as a problem
object and you can return it back out
I'm fine with that by the way I have no
desire for people to start manually
writing their own model binding
um maybe next year
um this is roughly what it looks like uh
uh so we have the type is a string and
the title is a string detail status
instance errors is an object uh it's not
an array it's an object so each error
has its own thing and then you've got
sub errors in there
um and then you have extensions which
means you can put anything you like in
there and that's uh that's forward
compatibility
um and then we can specify the example
here uh and tell it what the type is
type would normally be a URL saying this
is the type of error and then you can
click on that and it'll go yeah this is
exactly what you did wrong and why it's
a bad thing according to the ietf title
one or more validation errors occurred
Trace ID so that people can link it to
their logging system or their
distributed tracing system or open
Telemetry or whatever it might be and
and other cool stuff
so yeah
so before I go any further I want to
show you some of the really cool stuff
that this enables
if I can find
my
link here right
this is the repo with all the code so
the done that API and a really crappy
front end for it because I am not a
front-end person but you know it works
um and
this has got the the dundat folder is
there and in the done that folder I've
got there's the API that's the the
solution with the back end in it and
I've got a front end cleverly named
solution which has got that in there and
I've got an open API folder and in my
open API folder I've got my open
api.yaml file and responses and headers
ignore that that's just uh craft from a
mistake I made earlier
because it saves time so you don't have
to make the mistake during the talk I
find that very helpful
um and then if we go here you can see
that we have a link to open the redoc
docs
and redoc is this is an open source
project and it generates not Swagger UI
it generates actual uh documentation
this is a statically generated page it's
some HTML and some JavaScript and you
give it a reference to where your open
api.yaml file is and then it just
generates all of this information
and it's really really helpful
um you know down the side here uh
uh we say oh you can do get slash read
books and we've got a response sample
here and I can copy that and that's
application Json and I can see what the
payload is for this and all sorts of
other cool stuff I've got response
samples and I can expand everything so I
can expand this title out here and this
is all pulling these examples are all
being pulled from my handcrafted
openapi.yaml file which is why they make
sense
and they're not just random strings and
numbers and dates and and everything
else
and so that's that's really nice it's
it's quite nice I thought that was the
best thing ever until I saw this
so this is elements
um similar sort of deal
uh it seems to be built on web
components and I just like the idea of
using something in production that uses
web components because I haven't had
much chance to do that so this is uh
describing the done that API and in here
so we immediately see this uses um
implicito wolf flow and you can use this
to
um to go and get an authorization token
for it and then if I go into books and I
go to get list of completed books
not only does it demonstrate the thing
here and it says okay so you've got to
request the security on the request is
oauth 2.0 so you need a token here are
the responses the body is going to be an
array of this object with an idea title
and a finished ad
um but then over on the side here
we've got a kind of send API request
that won't actually work because one two
three is not a valid Bearer token but
look underneath that request sample C
sharp HTTP client so what redoc does is
it shows you the curl command to call
the API what elements does using a
plug-in from from somebody else is it
gives you request samples for how to
make this request
using any of these languages and
actually for c-sharp it'll show you how
to do it using HTTP client or restsharp
if you're a fan of restsharp but if you
want to do this from JavaScript then
it'll show you how to use the fetch XML
HTTP request so if you want to support
older browsers there you go that's how
you do that oh look there's a copy
button it's like stack Overflow just for
your API so people can just copy and
paste stuff now obviously for a lot of
languages n swag will generate you a
c-sharp client a strongly typed c-sharp
client from an open API specification so
that's there as well so this is just
another alternative way that you can
approach this
and the key thing here
is that the URL for this page is
renderlabs.github.io
slash LD nug 2012 uh
this is from a different repo
NDC LDN 2023
yeah it's the same
um
I tried this talk out first at
london.net User Group which by the way
if you live in London you should really
sign up for their mailing list and go
along they have some fantastic events so
yes
it's in the GitHub repo the application
isn't running anywhere I haven't got the
application running in as your app
services or or a kubernetes cluster or
anything like that but the docs are
still available and the docs are
generated
if we go over to the GitHub repo here
uh and
oh yeah no that's not the GitHub repo
where's the GitHub repo got
damn it
NDC LDN 2023
okay so we have done that and we have a
open API file in here and then if we go
back up to here we can go into GitHub
workflows and we can go into main.yaml
here
actually let me bring this up in vs code
no
there we go
right workflows main.yaml it's not a
huge great complicated thing
so build and deploy Pages uh we have uh
on the branch Main
um
steps check out obviously uh install and
build
so we're going to use dunda open API as
our working directory that's where our
yaml file is and their directories below
that with responses and examples and
schemas and whatever else and then we
run npx which is the magic npm thing
that installs something from npm and
then runs it immediately
re-docly CLI bundle this is the thing
that turns a whole selection of
openapi.yaml and Json files and mungs
them all together into a single yaml or
Json file
um and then that will produce a dist
slash done that slash open API and then
I use James ives's GitHub Pages deploy
action to push that folder dist onto my
GH Pages branch which then makes it
available as a a page
makes the HTML Pages available in there
um and
that's it that's that's the whole thing
um
so uh
the dist folder here where have we got
so yeah
this is the stuff that's already in that
dist folder so we have elements.html so
that elements page that really really
nice thing with all the code samples and
everything else down the side the C
sharp code sample and everything else
I don't even need to scroll that that
doesn't scroll that's it that's that
whole page that plus that yaml file that
I put a little bit of effort into
writing and creating examples in and all
that sort of thing that's the whole
thing and it just generates that lovely
thing and there's an export thing up at
the top right of that which will
literally dump the entire thing out as
pure static HTML so you could email it
to somebody and they could just open it
on their computer without needing to be
able to see the yaml file
um it's also got the redoc HTML it's a
little bit more involved but really not
very much that's just a link to the uh
latest read Oakley
um thing on there and we have the open
API yaml file which gets overwritten as
part of that build step
so yeah now I have the uh the standard
is maintained in my GitHub repository
the developers have all agreed that
that's it it's Source controlled we have
revisions we have code reviews when
someone wants to make a change to the
specification but now we can also inside
the GitHub repo generate redoxy or
elements um HTML and we could put
Swagger UI in there as well if we wanted
to
um but but we don't
uh so yes
um
so at the start uh yep we're doing good
I mentioned moonwalk open API 4.0 so
this is there's a bunch of people at
Microsoft working on this but it's an
open API working group there's kind of
like a standards body for this
um there are some issues with the open
API format uh the main one is when you
think about the structure you have paths
and then you have a path and then below
that you have the operations and the
name of each operation is the HTTP
method that you use get put post delete
uh which does not account for the fact
that actually sometimes API endpoints
are polymorphic and so you might have an
API endpoint where you can post stuff
and you could post I could make it so
that I had a single endpoint done that
um and you post something to it and then
it uses the structure of the Json
document to work out what it is you've
done and updates the thing appropriately
and that might be quite nice but I can't
describe that in open API 3.0 because it
just has a single post operation so one
of the things moonwalk does one of the
big things moonwalk does is it changes
that
and so under paths we have users so
that's just the path there and then we
have requests and then we have
initialize user so we've switched that
around that previously we'd have had
operationid colon uh initialize user
instead of doing that we actually use
initialize user as the name of the
operation and then below that we specify
that the method is put so this means we
can have multiple operations that use
the same HTTP method so that's quite
nice and there are a few other things
that um
they've just tidied things up and made
them easier for human beings to read and
write and and that sort of thing
um and the other big change is that the
Json schema in Moonwalk is actually
Jason schema so they have not subsetted
and then slightly superseted Jason
schema they've just gone if it's Jason
schema it's open API 4.0 schema as well
apart from that things are pretty much
the same it's not a huge change they
haven't changed things with a point of
changing things
so that is there's a GitHub repo
for that
github.com oai slash moonwalk you can
see some more examples in there you can
raise issues they've got a discussion
section so you can bike shed to your
heart's content and talk about stuff
so tools uh Swagger UI you're aware of
swaggy UI that's the thing that
swashbuckle and then swag throw in there
for you we also have redock
um which is the one of the options for
documentation and also the thing that
provides that command line interface
where you can bundle the yaml files and
everything else there's a thing called
wither shins which I put up there
because there's a thing called wither
shins I have no idea
um exactly what is very complicated it's
it's like latex or something
but one of the things so somewhere
inside widdishins there's a way of
taking an open API spec and just turning
it into markdown which I thought would
save people at my organization an awful
lot of time
even if they have to run the bloody
Azure function and then go and get the
yaml file from that and then punch it
through wither shins and then dump that
thing into there
uh thing there and elements at the
bottom that's my current favorite for uh
for documentation and stuff and then we
have plugins
so if you're using vs code for your
thing then open API brackets Swagger
close brackets editor is the sort of
standard there's that's the best plugin
for visual studio code there are several
but this one is maintained by 42 crunch
it's an inbound marketing tool so they
do actually maintain it and put some
effort into it and it works very nicely
if you use jetbrain's Rider then open
API it's a it's a plug-in but it's one
of those plugins that's automatically
installed and you get really nice things
in jetbrains Rider I'll show you some of
that in a second if you use Visual
Studio don't
um
so to be completely clear there by all
means use it for maintaining and editing
and creating and doing everything else
and right click publishing your asp.net
core applications and your W by all
means use it for that it's it's
fantastic
um but if you want to edit an open API
file manually use Visual Studio code
unless you already have Rider in which
case use Rider uh it's very nice
um and then
bundling so this is that important step
if you've broken your spec down into
multiple files to make it easier to
manage and do pull requests on and
everything else then redo you do npm IG
redoxy and then it just becomes
available and I am aware that there is a
sort of pushback against why do I have
to install node when I'm a net developer
and I feel you I completely agree with
you that is actually why I am writing my
own bundler speaking of things that I'm
writing
uh it's quite a lot actually
so render labs open api.web that's
already up on nuget that works and I'll
just show you very quickly what that
looks like in code
so here is my done that API solution
um so I've commented out the stuff
that.net new put in there for me that I
don't want
um so I've taken out this whole bit
about Builder environment is development
add endpoints API Explorer that's the
API reflection tool that swashbuckle
uses to generate open API
um add Swagger gen we can take that out
of there as well we've just got various
bits and pieces there and then in our
request pipeline we've got the
environment.is development we can take
out use Swagger and use Swagger UI those
came from swashbuckle and instead we can
use app.use static open API that's my
thing
um
there we go it's a bit bigger so yes
uh you can either sort of make sure that
your open API dot yaml file is copied to
your
um
uh folder along with everything else and
then you can specify a path to it or you
can embed it as an embedded resource in
the assembly so it's just a single dll
file and this will pull it out as a
manifest resource stream uh we specify
the version in there the UI path prefix
the Json path the yaml path it will
generate both the Json file and the yaml
file so we give it a yaml file but it'll
turn that into Json if something really
wants Json and then I want to put
elements documentation on here as well
so I tell it the path to use for
elements there's a re-docly if you
prefer re-docly for some reason you can
specify that as well that returns a
standard API endpoint convention Builder
which means you can put allow Anonymous
and all the other things on there you
can cache it you can apply cache headers
to it and all this sort of stuff so it's
a lot more configurable than what
swashbuckle throws out
um and I can show you that running
so here's the Swaggy UI this is being
generated that's that is running that
came out of there that's showing you the
Json and if I go to slag up Swagger
swagger no
uh V1 Docs that generates the elements
HTML so it's on the application and it's
in the GitHub repository it's exactly
the same because it's exactly the same
open API file because it's being bundled
using the same tool and published or
embedded using the same tool on both
build processes
so
that's there that that already works I'm
using that in a couple of things and
please do go ahead and use it
um things I'm working on the bundler is
um it's actually pretty much done I just
need to actually wrap it in the.net
command line tool and publish that
analyzers so this goes the other way
around and one of the things that I get
pushed back on this is people say ah but
if you're generating the open API stuff
from your application then you know it's
right
you know that it's it's right and you go
no you don't know it's right
you just know it's the same
you could very well be wrong in two
places automatically saving you fifty
percent of the effort of being wrong
um
so yeah but there is this is a good
point uh at least you know that the open
API that is being put out matches what
the API is actually doing even if that
is the wrong thing I would argue that
this is a full sense of security I'm
working on analyzers where you say hey
here's the open API file and it will
analyze your minimal API or your
controllers or your Azure functions and
it will actually tell you hey the spec
says that this returns a 404 but I can't
see anywhere in your code that you're
returning a 404 response so I'm going to
put a little squiggle here that says
you're not returning a 404 and raise a
warning with a code and you can then
Mark that warning as an error and make
it impossible for somebody to push
something through a CI build if the code
they've written doesn't do what the spec
says it does
so that'll be fun
openapi.test
is an attempt to replace horrible spec
flow gherkin style things if you can
describe your API in yaml why can't you
write the tests for your API in yaml so
you can put a request and then expected
response and this currently just
automatically generates X unit tests at
runtime and runs them using theories and
then code gen is the last bit and code
gen
remember I mentioned grpc and protobuf
earlier on what grpc generates when you
do a service is a base class that has
virtual methods for all the things you
said it would do and they're not
abstract they're virtual you don't have
to override them and if you don't
overwrite it and then somebody calls it
it will throw an RPC exception with a
status code that says not implemented so
it's basically throw new not implemented
exception HTTP has not implemented
exception so a code gen thing does is it
generates model classes and it generates
a base class with these virtual methods
it doesn't generate a controller it
doesn't generate a minimal API doesn't
generate these things it generates its
own sort of Base Class which you can
then inherit from Implement it's got
convenience things in there it will
generate automatic result codes but only
for the things that you specified in
your open API yaml file if you're going
why can't I return not found it's
because it's not in the spec
and then you do that in a class library
and then you create a web API project
and it will hook it up using minimal API
or you can create an Azure functions
project and it'll hook it up using Azure
functions and then that's going to be
pluggable so if someone wants to come
along and contribute an extension to it
it could generate something that hooks
it up to AWS Lambda or Google's app
platform or whatever that might be so
that one I'm kind of quite excited about
because I think that's that's the point
where I can go here there you go this is
the right way round to do it write the
contract generate the code from the
contract and then you know that the
thing matches because you're overriding
a method and you don't have the ability
to change it
there we go have I convinced anybody to
at least think about this show of hands
oh fantastic yes good people I love you
all go out into the world and spread the
poison
so yes uh references
openapis.org swagger.io that's bugged by
the people who originally started all of
this open API dot tools is a very
helpful list of things there's async API
which I suspect Ian would be interested
in which is somebody attempting to apply
all of this to messaging so you have
producers and consumers and uh and
things and you can describe the messages
and and all that sort of stuff the code
for this well this is at LD nug 2022 but
it's also at NDC LDN 2023
and that actually is the end of the
slideshow click to exit everybody go
home is anybody coming to pubconf
I'm terrified
thank you very much for coming I hope
you've enjoyed this I hope you've
enjoyed the conference and I hope that I
will see you all again next year if not
before take care bye
foreign